hi there steve kaufman um i wanted to
follow up my video of yesterday where i
i spoke of uh the need to learn and
experience things before we try to start
studying them
in a deliberate fashion and i got an
answer or a comment from
one person i don't know whether it was
on my blog the linguist on language.com
or
at youtube
and they said well surely what you mean
is
acquisition not learning
i said what do you mean i went back nah
well because your
method of language learning is largely
based on input therefore you really mean
language acquisition
which crash and defines this way as
opposed to learning
and i said no
we learn we learn all the time why is it
as much as i respect stephen krashen for
his position on many things
uh the fact that he chooses to call the
process of learning a language
language acquisition
that
that does not then make that some kind
of jargon
that we all have to use in fact i don't
like the word acquisition i don't
acquire a language i don't acquire words
they go in they get lost somewhere in my
brain
uh i learn i very much learn through a
process of of experiencing the language
through through reading and listening
mostly listening to things of interest i
learn because my brain learns i learn
every day as i experience new things i
don't acquire those things
i just learn and and the brain
starts to
form patterns
uh that help it
process and deal with this information
that's that's coming to it that's the
process it's not acquiring you're not
taking i've learned this word and and
now i have acquired this other word and
this other word i mean that's not it at
all it's a process of learning and
getting used to and and
labeling things so that that we're able
to deal with them because we don't want
to have to
think it through from scratch every time
so the brain starts to form
some some patterns that help it
then
quickly deal with something that that
they have already experienced before and
that's a gradual process of learning
call it acquisition i don't care what
you call it but that someone should take
the trouble to comment and say well no
you don't actually mean learning you
should be seeing acquisition
it's this whole
jargonization of this very natural
process of language learning that i find
very annoying it's as if we need some
special jargon for how to walk
you know or how to breathe we don't need
the jargon
they talk you know
s l a
second language x acquisition
uh there's e s l in which english has a
second language as opposed to e f l
english as a foreign language then
someone came up with aal english as
another language
who cares
the process of learning is essentially
the same
you can have a person in an esl
situation in other words someone say
living in canada trying to learn english
who has less contact with native
speakers than someone
living in
some foreign country where it's e f l
but where they have english speaking
friends whereas the immigrant here may
in fact only have chinese speaking
friends
so what does it matter e s l e f l a e a
l i don't know
uh there's all kinds of these terms like
inter language
you know
interlanguage supposedly is this idea
that we're between
the language our native language and the
language we're trying to learn so we
haven't totally
switched to this new language well what
does it matter
the the language as i learn another
language i am gradually progressing yes
my native language influences how i use
that language yes it will always
influence how i use that language in
terms of pronunciation in terms of my
choice of words and so forth but
gradually as i develop new patterns to
deal with the new language
i'm more and more comfortable in the new
language it's a constantly
it's a constant state of progression why
termite interlanguage no if i'm speaking
russian as poorly as i speak it i'm
speaking russian i'm not speaking
interlanguage it's the same with
fossilization it suggests that there's
some objective
um event or some some
thing that's outside the control of the
learner
that causes them to fossilize and not be
able to
progress further in the language i don't
believe that
i think that there are things that make
language learning difficult when you're
beginning and even at a later stage and
if you have the determination
and if you focus and if you're motivated
and if you like the language and if you
surround yourself
with
uh
native speakers you will continue to
improve in the language some people may
do better than others in pronunciation
in their use of words some have a bigger
vocabulary but they all have the ability
to continue to improve they are not
fossilized
unless they choose to or don't have the
interest or quite satisfied with their
existing level in the language but it's
a subjective thing it's not an objective
thing and i mean i can't remember all
these other terms there's lots of them
uh
so uh language acquisition language
learning i prefer the term learning
because it's a constant
random process
whereby the brain
gradually gets used to something i don't
believe the brain acquires the language
like now i have it it's mine i don't
believe that's the process at all
so let's not have too much jargon when
we talk about language learning it's
unavoidable that there is some
we see it in in
grammar where you know just to get back
to the subject when i learned chinese
and japanese
i mean there isn't much grammar in
chinese and i never remember any grammar
terms when i was learning chinese or
japanese but now they've
you know not to be outdone by the people
who do uh you know russian and all these
other languages they have to come up
with special terms to explain things
that are
don't need to be explained we don't need
the jargon i remember in in korean where
a lot of the verbs the endings imply
uh you know in order to or
because or there's a bunch of meaning
that comes with the ending so they come
at the end well i have a term for this
it's called copulative
verbs
like are you kidding me we don't need
that there's a verb it has this ending
it means this so i think i've gone on
long enough on this subject but i must
say when i saw that comment about
you really mean to say language
acquisition
it kind of
made me think about how much
the simple natural process of language
learning
is basically disrupted by all of these
supposedly well-meaning people
who invest so much time in coming up
with all kinds of complicated
explanations terminology and so forth i
am sure that will generate a lot of
criticism from my linguistics friends
thank you